when you put your blood sweat and tears
into creating something for building
something it's like a child but just at
the start don't accept the limitation in
a world that's changing so quickly the
biggest risk you can take is not taking
any risk
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believed and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and make a
difference using it so let's start your
day off where I grab your cup of coffee
and sip on today's message take risks
over to you Elon Musk one of the most
difficult choices I have ever faced in
life was was in 2008 I think I had I
think maybe thirty million dollars left
thirty or forty one dollars left in 2008
I had two choices I could put it all
into one company and then the other
company would definitely die or split it
between the two companies and but if I
split it between two companies then both
might die and you know when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something or building something it's
like a child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it surprised I split the
money between two fortunately thank
goodness they both came through I think
one of the healthiest things that you
can do in life is to figure out the end
I think too many people force
restrictions on themselves where they
say I can do this or I can do this and
they just accept that limitation
just because somebody else might have
put that limitation on you or you
haven't seen somebody else do that
combination before doesn't mean that you
can't what I love doing
whenever I get faced with that
impossible question and for I get asked
so many times from you guys in the
audience how
do this I have a choice this or this I
always try to think how do you do both
default to the end instead of the or
default to both instead of one and yes
focus is a real thing and yes if you're
trying to do a thousand things your
focus will be split and you probably
won't do anything well but just at the
start don't accept the limitation try to
ask yourself that question because you
will surprise yourself with how
resourceful you are and especially if
you have two competing interests if you
can find a way to do them both together
somehow última asking that more powerful
question you'll lead to a powerful
result and it may not get you to doing
all thousand things that you want to do
but two you can do I don't accept that
you can't be a great husband and a great
entrepreneur at the same time I don't
accept that I refuse to accept that I
Irana ask myself how do I do both how
can it be a great husband and how can it
be a great entrepreneur when you just
lift the limitation from yourself when
you just ask yourself that question
it opens up potential paths I've got a
new dog Tristana this is day three with
her I'm making videos she's got her bed
over down there on the side she's with
me 24/7 while I train her she's crying
and it's either I need to go look after
her or I need to make my videos I refuse
to accept that limitation I will bring
her on camera and listen this might even
be the best video yet by having the
cuteness on here it might be the best
video yet so just by reframing the
situation by refusing to accept the
limitation and saying how can I do both
I either look after her or I make my
youtube videos I'm either a great
entrepreneur or I'm a great husband I'm
either gonna do Tesla or I'm gonna do
SpaceX ask yourself how can you do both
you may not get the answer but most of
you aren't even asking the question you
just have accepted the limitation and
hopefully after this video it starts to
open your mind now I have a special
bonus clip for you but before that
question of the day I want to know what
are two things that you have combined
two things that seemed impossible to do
at the same time and yet by asking the
question by refusing accept the
limitation you found it I want to know
inspire me inspire believe nation
leave your comment down below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot I've been
spread so and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
sometimes a smart person comes in and
they've already been taught of certain
ways or their minds already been built
up in a certain way there are way way
too conservative way way too safe and in
the world of business sometimes it gets
ugly you know sometimes it gets dirty
sometimes there are some risks you got
to take you just got to take and it's
not conventional risk it's not
conventional thing that I'm supposed to
be doing this no you can't lean oh
there's some times that you got to do
some stuff that you can't read in any
book or any video some value tainment
literally there are certain things in
business that's like what do I do in a
situation like this I'm working on a
book right now I'm flying over to New
York to talk to a handful of major
publishers because they want me to
publish this book that has to do with
specifically on how to process issues
they once we learn how to process issues
but still if you're too conservative
you're gonna be toast in the world of
business there's gonna be times in
business they have to do certain things
that no one's gonna think about but
smart people typically just go to to
abide the rule is what they follow not
lost not lost not regulations rule it's
a different story they're afraid of
breaking rules sometimes in a world
that's changing so quickly the biggest
risk you can take is not taking any risk
and I really think that that's true
right and a lot of people I think think
that you know whenever it comes to
whatever you get yourself into a
position where you have to make some
some big shift and direction or do
something you know there are always
people are going to point to the
downside risks of that decision and
locally there may be right right I mean
if for any given decision that you're
gonna make there's upside and downside
but in aggregate if you are stagnant and
you don't make those changes then then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks and life is all about
taking risks and the one thing I've got
a little sign up in my office that says
that done is better than perfect and it
is so difficult to make people in the
company understand that it is so
difficult if you don't take a risk you
won't make progress that's such a issue
I started I started
to our employees about taking thoughtful
risks and two things happen
the first thing I happened was in a town
hall like this I got a question from an
employee saying will we have a seminar
to learn how to take thoughtful Tristan
has no crap we did your mother teach you
one time she must have that you don't
cross the road when there's a truck
coming your way the next time you kind
of learn that you don't all you can run
over you got two choices they said you
don't know what seven are to teach you
hard not to take a risk or how to take
it thoughtfully you've got to have it in
your head and mind that says that a risk
reward equation makes sense you do it in
life at home you do it when you get up
but you know when you get up from your
bed you're taking a risk you could fall
off the bed you could fall in the
bathroom and injure yourself you could
choke on your toothpaste you could we
took a risk right so who taught you
about that nobody did why would I teach
you in business how to take a thoughtful
risk a thoughtful risk is a risk that
doesn't always turn out to be a loser if
it does you're fired if you make a
mistake one time it's cool if you make a
mistake a second time the same one then
I have to ask how much intelligence you
have if you do it a third time you
should go do it my competitor so yes
it's actually not that difficult to
fathom it's really a very simple rule
it's common sense and that is a it took
a long time for people to understand
that and so people conventional wisdom
will drag you down words it's just have
to be willing to take these thoughtful
risks and not be not have 100% data
every time you just will not you will
never have 100% of the most important
word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be kind of like a
little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details